[TED Fellows]
[Shape Your Future]
(King cobra growl)
That’s the beautiful growl
of the world’s longest venomous snake:
the king cobra.
They’re the only snakes
that build a nest to incubate their eggs.
Apt to their scientific name,
Ophiophagus hannah,
meaning a snake-eater,
they eat other snakes,
including their own kind.
Growing up to five meters,
they possess enough venom
to kill 10 people in a single bite,
or even an elephant.
King cobras might be
intimidating to most people,
but I was always fascinated by them.
I've been studying this legendary species
for the last 20 years.
Fifteen years ago,
I was bitten by a king cobra
while rescuing it from a house,
which otherwise would have been killed.
There is no antivenom
for Indian king cobra,
so I was certain I would die
in about 30 minutes.
The bite was in my hand.
The pain was moving up my arm
towards the heart.
The pain was so excruciating
that I actually begged the team
to just let me die
rather than stay in agony.
I remembered I had stocked a few vials
of antivenom from Thailand,
meant for Thailand king cobra,
which I decided to experiment
with on myself.
But the Thai antivenom failed,
and we had to stop the treatment.
But here I am, a ghost?
No, the king was kind.
It injected a very small quantity
of venom into my hand,
which wasn't enough to kill me.
My mother hoped
that this near-death experience
would finally stop my snake obsession.
But no.
For those three
painful days at the hospital,
all I wondered was if the king cobra
was one species, as science believed,
then why didn't the Thailand
antivenom work on me?
It became apparent
that we were missing something.
King cobra was first described
scientifically in 1836,
after which many speculated
there could be different species,
but no one had ever established it.
This became my research topic.
For seven years after the bite,
I traveled across king cobra habitat
in South and Southeast Asia.
And this is what I found.
King cobras, despite being the
most curious, majestic snakes
are disliked, feared and hated
by most people on the planet.
They're killed on sight for food,
poached for skin,
for traditional medicinal purpose
and for pet trade.
And of course, their habitats
are under severe threat,
like many other species.
But we also found an answer
to this 185-year-old question
of species complex.
My research has shown that king cobra
is actually four distinct species,
not one, as everyone thought.
Now that is why the Thailand antivenom
did not work on me.
So what does this finding mean?
I found king cobras
differed from each other
by one to four percent genetic makeup.
So what does this discovery
mean for the king cobra?
Well, imagine there's a tsunami
or an epidemic on an island
inhabited by a particular
species of king cobra.
We could lose that whole species.
In other words, one habitat destruction
is the loss of an entire species
we have yet to understand.
Resolving species confusion
is highly important
for the conservation planning,
biological control,
treatment of diseases and snakebite.
According to the International Union
for Conservation of Nature's Red List
of Threatened Species,
king cobras are not given much attention.
My discovery calls for an urgent
reassessment of each species status
and conservation efforts.
As a direct conservation measure,
we at Kalinga Foundation rescue
king cobras from distressed situations.
So far, we have rescued close
to 375 king cobras,
monitored about 50 plus king cobra nests
and helped release over 500 hatchlings
back into their natural habitat.
We partner with communities
and invest in creating awareness
among local people,
especially kids, who urge their parents
to choose rescue over killing.
We encourage students
to participate in our research
and conduct capacity-building training
for snake rescuers and forest officials.
King cobras are potential
flagship species among snakes.
Declaring it as such
will be a big win for the species,
to my senior scientists
and the forest they inhabit.
What is interesting is
these are the same tropical forests
of South and Southeast Asia,
which has seven of the world's
36 biodiversity hotspots.
And these also contribute 68 percent
to the global carbon sink.
In other words, my team and I
are doing all we can
to say what we now know are four species,
and I welcome you to join us
in conserving the beautiful king cobra.
Thank you.